I was upstairs we're here at our uh
office complex I'm gonna make it sound
bigger than it really is yeah no no no
no it's the old Howard Hughes aircraft
company that I purchased it's well over
85 000 square feet it's like Stark
Industries here but I was upstairs and
it's I can hear everything and I heard
you show up and instantly felt everybody
here in the building got very happy you
have a people are happy to see you you
must find that a lot yeah I I okay I
think there's a couple reasons I've done
a lot of things where I'm your best
friend you know like for 10 years I was
your best friend on How I Met Your
Mother like in the house and I've been
Paul Rudd's best friend in movies like a
thousand times so people feel relatable
I think also I have to personally work a
little bit hard at happiness like
internally interesting and so that
manifests I think out outwardly so it's
a conscious choice you think that you're
making every day to be a happy person I
wake up I have to work like a little
harder to get to zero and then I like
push it yeah and then I push it little
past you know it's interesting it's the
probably a lot of a lot of people might
say it's the last thing they would
expect because you have well first of
all you brought you brought a lot of
people a lot of Happiness myself
included thanks you've done so much
really funny work and I'm gonna tell a
personal story which is when you were
shooting uh your Muppet movie you did
the sweetest thing I think I ran into
somewhere on the Warner Brothers a lot
and no one had ever done this for me
before you said hey if you like if you
have any young kids which I did come on
by and watch me shoot a scene and my
kids were electrified and you couldn't
have been nicer about it so you're a
genuinely uh nice person so when I hear
that you have to start a little below
zero in the morning it makes me I wish
that was not the case I wish you know
but everyone has their semi struggles
everyone's got their stuff yeah mine's
not bad by
by any means but like I found a note
from my that I wrote to my parents when
I was like five years old they actually
had it framed for me I guess I've always
been this way it said uh
in like little kid chicken scroll now I
know that no one likes me hate Jason
alright guys I signed off real strong I
signed off I signed off hey Jason
wow where was this coming from was this
was this some sort of weird emotional
dysmorphia or do you think kids really
didn't like it I I assume emotional
dysmorphia the thing that's like moms
get it so hard because at the top it
said dear Mom and Dad but then I crossed
out and Dad oh
wow yeah poor moms oh no I like decide
at the last minute not dad's okay
[Laughter]
indictment when you find actual proof
like that I know my parents found a
letter that I wrote when I was six that
said stop me before I kill again
yeah and uh no but but it is it is like
I remember uh I kept journals uh in the
70s when I was a really young kid and so
much of it as I recall was was about how
anxious I was and how nervous I was and
I didn't want to go to school tomorrow
and please help it be okay and just and
I look at it now and I think what was
that kid so anxious for yeah yeah I look
back and wish I could have said like it
all it all works out okay but I was also
like six four since I was 12. I was
always just a little things were just a
little off at least they felt that way
you were a good athlete you were you
played basketball right yeah well I
idolized my brother who's like a star
athlete and so I set out to like try to
impress him and I became pretty good as
a result well I just thought of
something that's kind of funny
um about little kids writing stuff and
the Muppets uh-huh when we I haven't
thought about this in a long time when
we finished the Muppets we did a test
screening just for little kids oh that's
great it was so cool it was an audience
filled with little kids and then we had
them fill out
um forms after about what they liked and
didn't like my character's name is Gary
and so they said uh uh you know what did
you like about the movie Muppets are fun
you know there's things like that songs
are nice
what didn't you like about the movie and
one kid wrote Gary's face
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah it was real easy it was a young
Timothy chalamet he's at the screening
he was he was like eight and he's right
compared to his face that's right my
faces
get him that's uh that's fantastic
that's the best this is the best you do
have those moments where no matter what
you achieve in this business and you've
achieved quite a bit it doesn't matter
I'm always reminded there's something
very humbling we're all about five
seconds away
from being brought right back down to
how we felt about ourselves in third
grade yeah 100 I don't think I I one of
the really important and things I
learned and I learned it early luckily
but it caused like a little like a
version of a breakdown was you you're
really indoctrinated to believe like
these things are gonna do it yes and
then if you're like crazy lucky enough
to achieve the things then you find out
oh it doesn't do it it's like a scary
moment yeah well I have witnessed that
with people time and time again I've
talked about this before but I call it
the Revenge of the nerd syndrome where
people grow up and they think if you're
unpopular or you don't feel very good
about yourself
the fantasy is I'm going to become
famous and it's going to fix everything
and of course it doesn't and then what
you see sometimes is Rage which turns
into depression yeah because a rage
turned inwards is depression and that's
what I I think happens to a lot of
people and it's just scientific it's
they think because I'm thinking about it
you would had
so much success in your 20s and in you
know really at an early age yeah that
you probably came up against it you
start to get into your early 30s you
realize well wait a minute I've been
I've made hit movies uh I have
think done everything you can do in this
meeting my star of a huge sitcom for
years nine years
um I I can say I want to make them bring
back the Muppets and it happens you have
that ability and yet
you realize something I'm not thrilled
I'm not thrilled with with what's
happening yeah I think that I I was like
making a mistake where
I bracketed those things from real life
like when this stuff is done and
accomplished I will then go live a great
real life
and but then you're doing this stuff
every day for years and years and years
and then you I started to realize oh I'm
missing it like my friends are having
brunch and kids and like all this stuff
and I'm like I wrote another script you
know like something I'd missed something
along the way I think also like
the very thing that makes you able to do
it might be the thing that kills you if
you don't like take your um foot off the
throttle especially if you felt awkward
as a kid there's a real like I will show
them quality that is like really helpful
motivation like watch this I don't know
how to swear here yeah yeah you're
actually encouraged okay oh great yeah
you know but you're like watch this
yeah sorry I knew it yeah
we didn't say the F-bomb we meant like
damn it dogged on it I thought maybe we
were gonna swear like you were gonna
promise it yeah when I was wandering
through these things
20 minute walk through this office today
I knew that this was coming through our
research and development it was a
facility in our Laboratories I knew it
no but like uh so so a really
interesting I I tend to note these
things and try to remember them but my
best friend is a really smart guy
um Irish guy and um for you to call us
best friends
it's really sweet I meant it when I said
that at the beginning
yeah no please continue I wrote
something like seven years ago and uh
and it never got made and and you know
how it goes you know it's like a
parabola your relationship to the
business and things are nice at the
moment and got a call maybe hey maybe we
can make that movie after all right
and I was sitting with my friend I have
a really lovely house and an orchard in
Ojai and I was sitting there and this
thing came out of my mouth I said gosh I
hope
I hope I make this movie that'll show
them
and then my friend looked at me and he
kind of like looked at the Orange Grove
and he said Jason at this point in Our
Lives who is them it was a really
important thing they like shook
something loose yes yeah who's them
anymore
um and they don't care right right well
first of all I know exactly who they are
right and I am gonna show that
damn Charlemagne
well I'm sorry but what has he got that
I don't got he couldn't be more your
opposite activities what are you talking
about
we are both very good looking nothing
talented young actors
and for you to say it you know
we actually had a complete side note uh
uh a good friend of mine is uh Uncle to
uh Mr Timothy chalamet and years ago we
were doing this week of shows at
Comic-Con my friend Rodman said is it
okay if I bring uh my son and my nephew
along and I went sure and they came
along I don't even remember this so they
came to our like rap party yeah you know
no one was talking to them so I was
chatting with them and then I swear to
God he hits like a year later or two
years later I was telling people on our
staff
you know Timothy chalamet was at our rap
party and they were so enraged and I
said I I brought him around I introduced
him to all of you and you were like yeah
move along to work yeah that's right so
young he was so young yeah but I mean I
think some of the people in our staff
beat him
they had cudgels we beat people yeah it
was that kind of part you know the
parties where if you see someone who's
young and doesn't belong there yeah go
get them you get them so we uh we really
beat the out of him him up
and then they were like oh you think
he'll come back he used to be really
good looking until you guys got home
yeah yeah no no he was really ugly and
our beating we beat him
he beat him with a pretty stick yeah we
sure did he owes his career to us
he got radical plastic surgery after our
beating and the doctor took off the
bandages and like oh my God I'm gorgeous
you could be in June that's what the
doctor said